foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
good evening and welcome to a special
edition of Piers Morgan uncensored from
here the governor's mansion in
Tallahassee Florida this is the home of
Florida's governor Ron DeSantis the man
that many think could be the next
president of the United States Miranda
Santos will soon deliver his State and
estate address he's set to outline his
agenda and highlight his possible 2024
presidential campaign the Santos has an
even bigger lead more than 20 points in
the survey that we showed you just
yesterday the news comes as DeSantis top
Republican rival former president Trump
faces new legal trouble I just spent
more than an hour with the government
and we covered a wide range of issues
from Ukraine I was a bit surprised I
think some people were that you seem to
be almost dismissing it kind of that's
not true kind of local dispute it's time
working at Guantanamo Bay you authorize
the use of force feeding some of the
yeah the detainees who are on Hunger
Strike I was a junior officer I didn't
have authority to authorize anything and
in Iraq we could defeat them on the
battlefield without even blinking an eye
two how he proposed to his wife we were
out on the balcony and just kind of
dropped to the knee and he did oh yeah
of course so you took the knee Governor
yeah yeah that's the only time I take a
knee is for that one what he really
thinks of Donald Trump you made a fatal
error in your relationship what's that
Donald Trump you got too popular
and of course the burning question
everybody wants to know the answer to Is
he gonna run do you think you can beat
bud I think so so you're running them so
here it is me one-on-one with Governor
Ron DeSantis in the governor's mansion
well first of all thank you very much
indeed welcome to the free state of
Florida I've come all the way from
London for this so uh you know that's
because London like most cities in the
world right now and most countries in
the world they're all beginning to ask
the same question who's this guy Ron
DeSantis
are you aware of this I am and uh we've
been able to see a little bit of that
and look I have the privilege of being
the governor of one of the most dynamic
jurisdictions in the world right now if
you look over the last four or five
years the amount of people that have
decided to move uh to Florida the just
visit Florida or even just look to
Florida for inspiration has been unlike
anything we've seen in the state's
history so uh we've got a lot of
tremendous people here we've got a lot
going on that's positive and we're not
afraid to lead the way I want to start
with a positive quote which you're going
to really like
and then move on to some negatives that
other people have said so it's going to
start Wellness okay this is from a guy
called Richard Littlejohn he writes for
the Daily Mail newspaper in the UK also
a Florida resident for many decades and
he's a friend of mine and he wrote this
recently DeSantis is living proof that
when conservatives govern as conviction
conservatives committed to Freedom Light
regulation low taxes strong borders and
proper policing and don't crumble in the
face of militant wokery voters lap it up
what's your response to that first well
is that a good categorization I mean why
you think you've been successful I think
oh that's true
um I think you just think of environment
we've done more on conservation for our
Everglades but this is like things that
really matter to people I'm not trying
to control their lives I'm just trying
to make the environment better crime or
Law and Order we are not dealing with
letting criminals out or going soft I
actually removed a Soros back prosecutor
from Tampa who said he wasn't going to
follow the law uh kovid we made sure
that we protected people's freedoms
people knew they could come here and do
well and yes we have no income tax we
have one of the lowest per capita tax
burdens in the country lowest per capita
debt Burns in the country and the
largest budget surplus in the history of
the state we have more people
significantly more people employed today
than we did pre-covered a lot of the
lockdown States still haven't gotten
back to their pre-covered employment
levels and so I think what we've done is
worked and I think people have responded
positively
all this has made you very popular in
Florida I mean just anecdotally being
here for a few days I've been completely
stunned frankly by the amount of
adulation you get from Floridians but as
your star has risen as you know
out of come the knives this is from
Vanity Fair they said you're a wannabe
autocrat already governed the Sunshine
State like a Banana Republic you're the
Genghis Khan of social issues using
every opportunity to Target and demonize
groups that have already been targeted
and demonized throughout history
um Trevor Noah called you an ignorant
racist
Stephen Colbert a gaping leap
Seth Meyer said you were cruel sadistic
stupid repulsive ghoulish when you see
this kind of hatred what it says to me
is a journalist who's covered a lot of
presidential runs and political
maneuverings is that it means that
people are getting a bit worried about
you I think that's right I think I think
they see me over the target I'm
obviously coming at it from a different
perspective than they like to see those
are all people on the on the left and
sometimes far left but here's the thing
I think the reason why I won the biggest
landslide in the history of Florida for
for Governor's race is because that
criticism is so far removed from the
reality there's legitimate things we can
criticize everybody for including me but
when you start talking about being an
autocrat all I do is I look at my
Constitutional Powers and I govern in a
way to advance the principles that I
believe in the criticism really falls on
deaf ears and I got it from all quarters
for the whole time I was governor I mean
you know during covet I was the number
one Governor being attacked I criticized
you there you go and I discovered today
what I tweeted about you historically
there you go and I found a tweet I think
in 2021 where it looked like Florida's
record was not going to be good on
Covert because you've been
one of the first people in America
certainly to bring back freedoms for
people and I was quite scaling I said
this guy's going to have blood on his
hands actually it didn't turn out that
way actually you were very bold in a lot
of the stuff you were doing Bolder than
many other Governors and it turned out
in in many areas you were Vindicated
well here's the thing excess mortality
lowest in this in the Sun Belt even
lower than New York and California for
all cause excess mortality and then of
course economically in Freedom we've
done way better now listen I was very
concerned about Kobe because I've got
more elderly than just about anyone I've
got 4 000 long-term care facilities I've
got condos with seniors stuffed in them
all across so this and I'm a tourism
state so this was a huge existential
threat to Florida one of the other
criticisms is used against you is about
your personality
it probably comes from people who don't
know you very well because those who do
who I've spoken to tell a different
story but you're being depicted in some
of the national media as very intense
quite boring
um Charisma devoid
you know someone reviewed your book and
said he would launch any charm offensive
unarmed well I appreciate the knocks on
the book it's the number one book in
America Far and Away I've sold more than
any non-pre president in the history of
the country in terms of the first week
so we've been doing pretty good A lot of
people like it there's a hostile New
York Times review help sales yes with
conservatives of course it does yes so
here's the thing I think you know there
is these are people who are in the
political class journalist class
politicians and like DC in particular
they get mad I don't do the cocktail
parties I don't like rubbing elbows with
other people I like doing my job and
then spending time with my family that's
just what I do a lot of the people that
are criticizing you know they would say
oh he doesn't do well with with with
donors he doesn't glad hand with them
and yet I raise more money than any
non-presidential candidate in the
history of America are you kidding me so
we tend to do we we do well but I do
think that you know I deal better with
regular people than I do with some of
the people in the political class your
book you start with a quote from Sir
Winston Churchill the greatest of all
britons
um certainly as far as I'm concerned
it's about courage and it says courage
is rightly considered the foremost of
Virtues for upon it all others depend
why did you choose that as the quote to
kind of set up the book because I think
what what I've been called upon to do as
governor is make the right decisions
when it wasn't easy I've got to do
what's right and I've got to stick by
that and I've got to be willing to take
the arrows and I think we need more of
that in terms of our leaders now is
Churchill a hero of yours absolutely why
well he saw the danger very very early
on he spoke out and he rallied Britain
in a very difficult time and I think he
was just very inspirational he's a
strong leader of course but he had a way
with words I mean how you say these
things to really stir people's
patriotism emotions I think is something
that um that I've always admired you've
achieved a lot in Florida and you had
this thumping win one and a half million
more people voted for your second time
round it's Governor an amazing
validation of what you've been doing
could you do that nationally think you
could I think one of the things that was
interesting about my election is the
voters in Florida overwhelmingly thought
the country was on the wrong track but
they thought Florida was on the right
track we're very tough on crime the
policies in Washington are to be more
weak on crime we believe in and Stuart
good stewards of the environment but I
don't want to control everyone's
Behavior with some of the stuff that's
going on and we have really fought
against the woke ideology what I want to
know is where did this come from so tell
me a little bit about your upbringing I
know your parents your father was a
Nielsen TV engineer for TV rating
because back then you had to put the Box
on the television sets and he was
physically doing that and your mum was a
nurse and they still live in Dunedin I
think in Dunedin Florida founded by
Scots yes indeed yeah
um tell me about them and about the
influence they've had on you so my
father was born is from Western
Pennsylvania town Aliquippa that's a
steel Town his father worked in the
steel mills my mother's from Youngstown
Ohio another steel town so this is Blue
Collar gritty
religious patriotic my household values
really reflected that working class
upbringing and basically what I think
instilled In Me Is You know I love the
country trusted God but just really
believed you don't get anything handed
to you in this life the other question
I'd do is look in the mirror every day
and think
am I about to do something my mother
will either like or dislike there you go
do you have that same absolutely guiding
principle absolutely you did a press
conference this morning and you were
responding to the reports rumors of
Donald Trump potentially being indicted
to
and you gave an interesting response
very sort of supportive of him in a way
by saying yeah you know I think what's
happening there is outrageous it's
political posturing by this deer and so
on in New York and they should be
focused on more important things but you
also repeated twice you didn't have any
knowledge of hush money being paid to
Pawn Stars
was I right to
feel that there was a slightly
sensorious tone to that that kind of
thing is just not anything you would
ever get involved well I think it's
there's a lot of speculation about what
the underlying conduct is that is
purported to be it and yeah the reality
is that's just outside my wheelhouse I
mean that's just not something that I
can speak to so uh you know I hope it
doesn't come to where you end up seeing
this going forward I mean look if you
are a very strident prosecutor and this
guy's on the left and you're not
Prosecuting a lot of crimes Manhattan's
gotten less safe you're going to go
after somebody on the other side for
some novel offense that just does not
Inspire confidence and people see that
as weaponizing the justice system so so
I think it's fundamentally wrong to do
that and you know I just made it be
known but who you know we'll see maybe
it won't come to that I mean we haven't
seen anything firm yet does personal
conduct in any leader politically in
America does it matter
how you behave as a leader I mean I
think at the end of the day what a
leader you really want to look to people
like our founding fathers like what type
of character it's not saying that you
don't ever make a mistake in your
personal life but I think what type of
character are you bringing so somebody
who really set the standard is George
Washington because he always put the
Republic over his own personal interests
when we won the American Revolution
Washington surrendered his sword George
III said well if he surrendered there's
no intrude into private grief without
him we could have had King Pierce that's
right I know but George III said he's
the greatest man in the world if he
gives up power and so I think the
personal is more about how you handle
your public duties and and the kind of
character that you bring to that
endeavor how important is truth to you
we live in a world where people talk
about my truth as if somehow you can
create your own version of the truth to
me facts of facts the truth is what it
is it's the truth
people feel whether it's been in the US
or the UK with Boris Johnson they feel
like there's been a departure from truth
being an important factor of leadership
a hundred percent I mean look look truth
is essential we have to agree that
there's a certain reality to the world
we live in and if we can just create our
own facts then we're never going to be
able to agree on anything or never
really be able to do policy in a way
that makes sense and so yes it's not
your truth or my truth it's the truth
you went to Yale and Harvard
it was described as a blue collar kid
from Tampa among the Communist
millionaires you said you were the only
person to leave either of those places
more conservative than you started I
think so I mean you know I wasn't
political when I got there because where
I came from I didn't know if you're
Republican Democrat when I got there you
had a lot of militant leftism one of
Yale's mottos is for God for country for
Yale but you get in the classroom no way
I mean it was very anti-religion
particularly Christianity and and very
anti-americanism and really adopting a
lot of the left-wing mantras of the day
and I kind of rebelled against that
because I'm like wait a minute you know
I'm proud to be an American uh I'm
wouldn't be here if I if in any other
country perhaps and so this is something
that that I rejected and then by the
time I got to Harvard I was already set
they weren't going to change me it's
most extraordinaries to watch the way
campus a campus sort of ideology is gone
I mean if it was bad then it's
immeasurably worse now this way
Cardiology has got a grip not just in
America but in the UK and around the
world it's not good for them because
when they get into the real world their
assumptions have never been questioned
you should want your assumptions
question a university is about pursuing
truth it's about rigor and academic
integrity and giving people the
foundation so they can think for
themselves and be citizens of the
Republic not to impose ideology we want
there to be free speech on campus we
want the professors to come from a wide
variety of viewpoints you can't have
every Professor having the same leftist
Dogma in the class that's not good
education right I mean I lost a job
because I disbelieved Meghan Markle
there you go with her claims of racism
against the royal family I said I don't
believe it so I had to leave my job it
was completely insane when you think
about it no I'd be fired for believing
it that's true right that's true I mean
it's true
um
though my book beat print now his his
book had come out earlier number one and
then when I became I was higher than
Prince Harry we're all very grateful
what do you make of those two you have a
view of them I don't I mean you know I
think that um I really respected the
queen I mean I think she was uh really
elegant and I think her stoicism and I
think it was really good you know as the
younger Generations it's a little bit
more mixed I mean that's just the
reality
are they annoying I think for some they
are I mean look I'm not involved in that
blue I just kind of focus on but I think
for some Americans they can be
from Governor DeSantis after the break
[Music]
pop the kettle on this is the royalty
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book frankly it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses of Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
you had a choice when you left at
Harvard which was to take big money and
go into relatively easier work I guess
than what you chose to do but instead
you wanted to serve in the Navy that's a
big moment for you that decision why did
you decide to do that a lot of that was
you know in the wake of 9 11 the world
had changed you know I was growing up in
like the 90s in high school and then in
college graduated before 9 11. our
country didn't have a care in the world
when cold war was over there was
prosperity and people weren't even
thinking of that and then when the
towers fell it just it changed my
outlook and I know we didn't have a
draft or any of that but I was like look
you know I should be willing to to help
out here and I'll have time to do other
things in my life and so so we ended up
volunteering we did the Navy and at that
time I didn't know what I was in store
for but I ended up doing a lot of stuff
around the country and around the world
including being in Iraq and it was
really really valuable experience I mean
when you when you wear the cloth of your
country that's meaningful service and
the people that you meet along the way
are great but there's just a lot you
know Jack can he said people can look
back on their life with a great deal of
satisfaction and say I served in the U.S
Navy and I agree with them where were
you on on 11
you know I was um I think I had just
graduated college and was kind of not a
care in the world and all of a sudden
boom you know it happened and so I had
already been either accepted or planning
on going to law school and that's when I
decided to start looking into some other
other career choices that moment was a
pivotal moment in modern American
history in many ways Unleashed a whole
series of consequences
would you have done things any
differently if you've been running
America at the time obviously we're 20
years on from the Iraq War for example
which many viewed as an illegal conflict
potentially but certainly one that
created a lot of turmoil the rise of
Isis and so on would you have invaded
Iraq so I think in hindsight it's very
easy to make these things so clearly we
had to go to Afghanistan knock off the
Taliban and and decimate Al Qaeda I
would not have stayed in Afghanistan for
what we did I mean the idea that we were
going to turn that into a democracy it's
just a different culture and they're
they're organized differently and then I
think in Iraq what I saw there was you
know you said democracy when Saddam was
removed these are people cozying up with
the Iranians and so we now have a
situation where Iraq is basically an
Iranian satellite and Iran has probably
been our most significant adversary
certainly in that region you know since
the Shah fell so in hindsight I mean I I
honor everybody's service because I
think they did a lot of great things but
in hindsight has the Middle East gotten
better as a result of that I think
Iran's gotten stronger as a result of
that conflict you spent some time at
Guantanamo Bay obviously a very
contentious entity in many ways Barack
Obama campaigned in 0809 to close it and
didn't still open today clearly a lot of
very bad people went there but we now
know there were some who were detained
for over a decade and were innocent
people you were there in a legal
capacity did you have any qualms about
what was going on there about holding
people that long without trial well I
think that there should have been
military commissions I did support that
but what I saw because there was a
median there about they were being
mistreated in gitmo what I saw was
basically a professionally run prison
and there was different kind of
categories so the Khalid Shake Muhammad
is going to be like a maximum security
some of these other guys were like open
air play soccer all day who were viewed
as less of a a threat but what they're
trying to figure out is okay if we
release this person back to Afghanistan
are they going to engage in terrorism
against and that's hard to know
definitively so I think they tended to
err on the side of caution now I will
say these detainees would all say they
all said they're Koran salesman like
every one of them was a Quran salesman
and that clearly wasn't the case either
did you have any issues as a lawyer with
people being held that long with well
without any trouble but it's a tough
it's a tough thing when you have a
situation with terrorism and War because
they're not a nation-state and how they
they you can't try them I think in a
civilian court so you really need
military commissions I actually thought
I was going to be involved in military
commissions and they really just
sputtered they didn't get off the ground
they should have had those up and
running and it's some due process but it
isn't what you would get in a civilian
trial the Washington posted a big deep
dive on this today actually about what
you did out there one of the things they
said was that you authorize the use of
force feeding
who were on Hunger Strike was that true
so I was a I was a junior officer I
didn't have authority to authorize
anything there may have been a commander
that would have done feeding if someone
was going to die but that was not
something that I would have even had
authority to do so that's that's wrong
yeah yeah absolutely
what did you learn you then went to
Fallujah in 2007 that was the year of
the search really more American troops
died that year than in any year in in
since World War II I think so really
incredibly dangerous and and a lot going
on you were there as a legal counsel to
the commander of sealed Navy SEAL Team
One and obviously the seals weren't as
well known as they are I guess now
um but incredibly demanding job I would
think under a lot of pressure what did
you learn about yourself while you were
doing that well it's interesting so you
know we had folks all across allium bar
Province so like the headquarters was
Fallujah we had ramadi al-assad haditha
hit all these places and there were
operations every night and you know they
tend to work at night and so you're
you're just crazy out one day after
another after another for a six six and
a half month period
um but you know at the end of the day I
mean honestly I kind of felt honored to
be there because these are some of our
best people uh that I was able to kind
of hitch a wagon with and they were
making a good difference by the time we
left there were not Americans dying in
al-ambar Province anymore I mean Al
Qaeda and Iraq had been crushed The
anbar Awakening had happened and most of
the deaths at that point probably 90
percent were in the Shia areas with the
Iranian back forces so so it was a
successful deployment not just our
deployment but the Marines and the Army
who were there during that time did you
come under any personal attacks not
anything special I mean you know I would
travel from different areas but what
they would do is like if you fly it in a
helicopter they would do pitch black at
night so that they couldn't you know
shoot it down with an RPG but they would
not go in the daytime still quite a an
unnerving experience but you just don't
know I mean because the thing is we
could defeat them on the battlefield
without even blinking an eye but that
wasn't how they were fighting they were
fighting to try to say if you're going
convoying from ramadi to Fallujah we're
gonna try to blow up your convoy and so
it's just kind of like okay if the
numbers called the numbers called I want
to talk to you about another War Ukraine
uh I was quite surprised so I'll be
honest with you by what you said last
week about Ukraine describing it as a
territorial dispute it's picked up a lot
of blowback as you know only surprised
because of your military background
because you were on record as supporting
helping Ukraine after the invasion of
Crimea
do you regret actually just using that
one phrase well I think that it's a
territorial distance I think it's been I
think it's been uh you know
mischaracterized obviously Russia
invaded that that was wrong they invaded
Crimea and took that in 2014. that was
wrong what I'm referring to is kind of
where the fighting is going on now which
is that western border or eastern border
region donbess and then Crimea and you
have a situation where Russia has had
that I don't think legitimately but
they've had there's a lot of ethnic
Russians there so that's some difficult
fighting and so whatever the conflict
area that's what I was referring to and
so it wasn't that I thought Russia had a
right to that and so if I should have
made that more clear I could have done
it but I think the larger point is okay
Russia has not shown the ability to to
take over Ukraine to to topple the
government or certainly to threat NATO
that's a good thing they've been
weakened you now have the fighting in
those areas I just don't think that's a
sufficient interest for us to escalate
more involvement I would not want to see
you know American troops involved there
but the idea that I think somehow Russia
was was justified and that's nonsense
when I was in Ukraine interviewing
president zolensky last summer what I
was struck by was the utter resolve of
the people there which I suspect would
be exactly the same as somebody invaded
any part of America which was not to
give Putin an inch not an inch in fact
they wanted Crimea back and I think they
would they would take issue with it
being categorized I think they have the
right to that territory I just think
that's the source of the conflict it's
in those regions which there's likely
going to continue to be a lot of
conflict on that going forward so if I
could Snap My Fingers I'd give it back
to Ukraine a hundred percent but the
reality is what is America's involvement
in terms of escalating with more weapons
and certainly ground troops I think
would be a mistake so that was the point
I was trying to make but Russia was
wrong to invade they were wrong to take
Crimea what's your view of Putin
look I think he's got Grand Ambitions I
think he's hostile to the United States
but I think the thing that we've seen is
he doesn't have the conventional
capability to realize his Ambitions and
so he's basically a gas station with a
bunch of nuclear weapons and so for us
one of the things we could be doing
better is utilizing our own energy
resources in the United States we could
be permitting natural gas pipelines from
Marcellus doing a lot in in Alaska
that's where he gets all his power and
obviously he's influenced Europe uh by
by having so much energy so the way to
hit Putin is to hit him with energy but
I do think you look back all the defense
analysts and me in the past we
overestimated his conventional
capability this has been a huge blunder
for him uh huge costs and uh you know
we'll see what ends up happening with
his longevity and and power but but this
has been a this has been a loss for them
there is a move now to hold him
accountable for war crimes bombing
maternity hospitals and genocidal
activity in parts of Ukraine it's wiping
out whole cities maripole and others
which you support that I mean I think he
is a war criminal this ICC we have not
done that in the United States because
we're concerned about our soldiers or
people being brought under it but I do
think that that he should be held
accountable how does it end the Ukraine
war do you think that's the thing I mean
I think it's it's I think those regions
and the border and Crimea you know I
think are likely to uh to be a stalemate
for quite some time and you know
unfortunately a lot of people will end
up dying if that's the case but I do not
think it's going to end with Putin being
Victorious I do not think the Ukrainian
government is going to be toppled by him
and I think that's a good thing one of
the issues about it was well people were
saying okay well what happens if China
decides to invade Taiwan which may well
happen in the next couple of years if
they do is that also a a territorial
District so that yeah the the the the
the thing with territories just that's
where the fighting was you know there's
not as fighting on the on the on the
western side and you have situations
where there's ethnic Russians there and
it's just it's it's a it's a messy
situation but Russia did not have a
right to go into Crimea or to go in in
February of 2022 and and that's that
should be clear
and if China did invade Taiwan that
would be aggression absolutely it'd be
aggressive should get involved in in
that so I would say that Taiwan is a is
a strong Ally of the United States
um I think that that's a critical
interest I think it's for us but also
for our key allies like Japan and South
Korea and I think overall the number one
issue that we Face internationally is
checking the the growth and the rise of
China they're much more powerful I think
than root than Putin and Russia are and
they really represent the biggest threat
that we've seen to to our ability to to
lead since the Soviet Union
off the break out of the santis tells me
how he proposed to his wife
[Music]
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book frankly it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses off Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
I would I think so would you I think so
I mean I think from everybody in America
I think I think it's a security risk I
think they are harvesting so much data
uh on our citizens there's a whole bunch
of other apps and stuff that are out
there and honestly Pierce I got young
kids I don't want our kids on some of
this stuff and on sex education in
school what is your clear position on
that now so what our our position is
basically you know we don't want to be
injecting sexuality and things like
gender ideology and particularly the
younger grades and you know you do have
places around this country where they
will have kindergartners say Okay
declare what your gender is or tell a
student that they may have been born a
boy but maybe they're really a girl that
is totally inappropriate I think these
are things that parents should be taking
the lead on as they deem appropriate but
that should not be imposed in the in the
school system did you ever think you be
alive in a world where a six foot four
inch former male swimmer could suddenly
identify as female and start demolishing
women born to female bodies in
competitive swimming for example yeah
you know what I'm talking about pen it
just seems after spending three years on
the men's team unsuccessful and then
switching there and then you have the
situation you have that famous picture
of of the swimmer within the three women
and there are they're so much smaller
the runner-up on that was actually from
Sarasota and I did a proclamation from
the state saying she was the rightful
winner she was the best women's 500 yard
freestyle swimmer so it's taking away
opportunities from girls and women
athletes I completely agree I think it's
a mad debate talking of of young girls
actually a young woman that you met on a
golf range many years ago so there you
are you're on a golf range and you spy
two things one is it was a bucket of
balls that you have and there's this
very beautiful woman
who didn't know but she was called Casey
turned out to be your wife yeah you
didn't know that now she tells this
story and says that actually she was
looking over and eyeing with great
covetousness your bucket of balls your
version is that she was looking at you
and eyeing you up have you reached an
agreement about this so I thought she
was looking at me I really did and you
know we did have the balls and so I used
the balls as a way to start talking to
her but you know my view was like look
I'm what what's the worst she can do
she's not want to talk to me I'm like I
am not letting this opportunity go so we
went over there we started talking we
divvied up the balls hit him and then we
went out after that and kind of kind of
the rest is history but I think in fact
she was looking at the balls I do think
I was wrong when did you know this is
the one for me I mean I would say like
pretty early I was like this is
different and um you know I made sure to
to court her of course I got mobilized
to go to California then Iraq so we
stayed together through all that but I
told myself like as soon as I get back
from Iraq I'm popping the question and
so we ended up doing that and how did
you do that
oh I took her to a nice little Resort in
Florida and we kind of went out and we
were out on the balcony and just kind of
dropped to the knee and you just bended
knee oh yeah of course so you sent the
knee Governor yeah yeah that's the only
time I've taken knees for that one so
and she uh and you had a ring had a nice
ring and everything everything was
really good did she hesitate no no
immediately immediate yeah I think she
you know she had let it be known that
that she was happy and that that we were
ready to go to the next level as well so
I don't think it was anything that was
like a super shock but um but it was
good to get that get that one in the win
column when she got cancer she told very
moveling about this in a campaign uh
commercial for when you ran for governor
in 2022 but she taught for a
emotionally about it and gave a real
like
heartfelt assessment of you and I don't
want to you know bring your blushes here
but she said
when I was diagnosed with cancer I was
facing the battle for my life he was the
dad who took care of my children when I
couldn't he was there to pick me off the
ground I literally couldn't stand he was
at a fight for me when I didn't have the
strength to fight for myself
when you watch that because I don't
think you'd seen it before it went out
no and you see your wife crying as she
pays that kind of tribute to you what
did that make you feel well look you
know for sickness and in health good
times and bad I mean that that's the job
of a spouse and I I to have her thank me
publicly like that was was very
heartwarming I know it touched a lot of
people throughout the State of Florida
and you're right I didn't know what she
was going to say because she asked me I
want to go over this thing I said you
know don't worry about my filter don't
listen to anyone else you just speak
from your heart so she kicked everybody
out of the room when she when she filmed
it except the camera guy and she just
spoke from the heart no script know
anything and I think it told a lot of
people about kind of what we've gone
through as a family you know you never
want to see anyone go through something
like that but there is something a
little bit more poignant when you have a
young mother that's fighting for her
life with these young kids because no
none of these no kids should lose a
parent like that and so that I think was
a source of fight for her it was a
source of fight for me and we just had
such a great outpouring of support from
the community that it did lift her
spirits did you fear that you may lose
her so it's interesting you always have
that fear but I'm a data guy I went and
looked it up I said you're going to beat
it she's like and she didn't necessarily
want to hear that because she was so
scared just as anyone would be but I'm
like I've looked at the data I'm looking
at the treatments you know you're going
to be okay so I really felt confident
and we the doctors had a plan I talked
to doctors all around the country and I
didn't even tell them what the plan was
I was like okay what do you recommend
and they all said do the things that we
ended up doing so I felt really really
comfortable there was a big consensus
from people all over the country that I
talked to I knew it wouldn't be easy but
I absolutely thought she was going to
beat it what was the lowest moment do
you think I think the chemotherapy I
mean I think too I think at the
beginning when we get the because she
went to the doctor she felt something
the doctor cleared her they did a a
physical exam said that you didn't have
anything don't worry and like me if a
doctor said said I'm okay I would never
think twice about it she had a feeling
that there was just something wrong so
she really fought to get a mammogram and
so a couple weeks later we got it I told
her I was like you're fine and then it
came back and so I think that was really
really different that's a jolt moment it
really is because it totally changes
your life it changes your family's
trajectory everything all of a sudden is
up for grab so I think that was you know
one of the most difficult and then just
not knowing what to expect especially
before we saw a physician and one of the
cancer doctors we had no idea really
what we were dealing with apart from my
kind of side research that I'm pulling
up stuff from like Mayo Clinic and
researching so then that was tough and
then I would say the chemotherapy it
just it saps you when she was declared
cancer did she ring the bell did she she
did yeah yeah were you there yeah
absolutely I mean that moment for you oh
yeah yeah well you know here's the thing
well I know you're a tough guy Ron
DeSantis I know standing there is your
wife Rings the cancer we had a big hug
how did you celebrate
actually Guinness did you really we both
really like Guinness it's just something
and when I remember we we went to
Ireland Scotland years ago and like just
being in the pubs being able to do it
it's you know they said that that the
beer was um was all warm over there they
actually have Guinness extra cold Taps
so you'd get it I mean it's just
fantastic so you had a couple of puns
again that's right I bet it would
there was a incredibly sad time in your
life which was the loss of your sister
um Christina who died in London
it was reported she died of a pulmonary
embolism is that is that what happened
and she was leading a great life she
just got engaged I think to a British
guy her life was all ahead of her
and then Bang
it's all taken away and she dies at the
age of 30. what was that moment like for
you and your family well I think it was
just you know it kind of like a
shattering experience you know partially
because she was doing well she was very
happy she was over there and I remember
my Mom calling me my wife and I were on
our way back from church it was like a
Sunday off Sunday morning and she said
that you know Christina's in the
hospital she had a blood clot and so I'm
thinking like is she okay and she seemed
to be stable so she was in the hospital
for a couple days and then had the
embolism and died in the hospital and so
I just didn't think that that was
something that was even possible at that
point because I thought that she was
stable and so we were I mean you just
feel like you have your sibling you know
their their future was robbed and
um you know it's just something I wish I
could get back what did she make of of
you and what was happening with you
I was the big brother so we were 85 I
was seven years apart so we weren't
necessarily ever in like the same school
together any of that so I was kind of
like a little bit rarefied air in some
respects she always looked up to me
um and I think some of it was because I
was doing things she tried to measure up
to me and I told her I was like don't
worry about that I was like you just be
you and and do do what you can do and
you know she was very successful
um you know once she got out of school
she got her Masters and everything so
um but you know it just it's it's a it's
a tough thing you're clearly feeling
quite emotional thinking about it yeah
it's hard to think of a worse thing
actually for a family I think than
losing a sibling I mean I just think you
know people have their whole lives ahead
of them and when you're talking about
that age it's just it's a big tragedy
of his big rival Donald Trump
[Music]
foreign
this is the royal tea I'm Sarah Houston
his decision that's questionable not the
book frankly it doesn't do Andrew any
favors having this dripped back into the
media I think they really only care if
they come again Americans love that
Royal fairy tale common ground which is
desperately by the way what the two
houses of Windsor and Montecito need to
find is that what this is about here
inviting all his mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
welcome back this is that part of the
interview where I had to ask him the
burning question
let's get into the question you're not
going to answer
I guess yeah
let me ask you anyway and you can you
can bat it away because I'm not
expecting you to announce now but
everybody's assuming you're going to
announce reasonably sitting at a run for
president United States
are you so so I haven't made a final
decision on it I've told people I've got
a lot that I've got to do over the next
few months in Florida we're going to put
a lot of points on the board and then
we'll see how the dust settles after
that but I can tell you we just have a
lot of people that realize the country's
not going in the right direction and
believe that what we've been able to do
in Florida if we could apply that
nationally would kind of get America
back on track and back on our
foundations and so I take that very
seriously it's humbling that people have
come to me and and asked me to do it or
urge me to do it so stay tuned
that sounds like almost a yes it's a
stay tuned I mean why wouldn't you well
because I mean look I I've got a young
family I mean I've got I've got
different different uh obligations and
it's not the easiest thing in the world
uh to to go through and I also want to
make sure that you know I have a very
clear rationale for doing what I'm doing
all I'm interested in doing is getting
things done and accomplishing things I
don't need a title I don't need Fanfare
I just want to know that if I put my
mind to this if we ever did that and
were successful what could I do to make
a difference and and that's what I have
to have do you think you have what it
takes to be president of the United
States look I think what it takes is to
have a vision for the country uh have
the ability to exercise leadership and
being willing to stand in that fire when
it gets really really hot and and not
back down under pressure and I think I
have all those things you go to Great
endorsement from someone Ron DeSantis is
a brilliant young leader then Harvard
Law who would make a great governor of
Florida which turned out to be true he
loves our country he's a true fighter
and there's a ringing endorsement from
president Trump
products change a little bit I guess you
know it is what it is yeah I mean he was
a big fan no I mean I think and I think
you know we had a good relationship as a
congressman and I think one of the
reasons he got to know me is because I
saw this Russia collusion thing as a
farce from the beginning very few people
said that we had a handful of us in
Congress that were fighting back against
that uh and so I would go on TV and I
would defend him uh when it wasn't
popular and when it was kind of
politically risky but I just thought it
was the right thing to do and I thought
that he had good ideas for the country
so I wanted to do and then when I became
Governor his last two years as president
I was governor my first two years and we
worked very well together I mean he he
had a place in Florida he wasn't a
resident yet but he understood Florida
and really worked well with us to to
serve our state you made a fatal error
in your relationship what's that Donald
Trump you got too popular
well I I would say if you look at some
of the the change from that and all the
way up what's been the kind of the major
thing that happened that's that's
changed this tune was my re-election
Victory I mean that's just that's kind
of the market because many of his picks
in the midterms did badly and you who
had been you know he was a mentor many
ways I guess early on had this thumping
Victory uh and I guess if you're him and
you're desperate to get back to the
White House this was a bit of a
nightmare that you were getting such
validation in Florida you know my view
though is like look we should want the
country to do well I want other
Republicans to do well I'm not I I want
them to Eclipse me you know we're
setting a great standard in Florida
we'll have everyone up their game I want
other Governors to do to do a great job
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving you so far is it Ron
Ronda sanctimonious or meatball rock
well I can't even he went off meatball
wrong I can't uh I don't know how to
spell the sanctimonious I don't really
know what it means but I you know I kind
of like it's long it's got a lot of I
mean so we go with that that's fine you
know you can call me you can call me
whatever you want I mean just as long as
you you know also call me a winner
because that's what we've been able to
do in Florida has put a lot of points on
the board and and really take the state
to the next level at some stage I mean
have you read
um Mary Shelley's book Frankenstein I
have not okay it's a great book and
obviously it's spawned several movies
but there are prophetic words of warning
from Dr Waldman to Dr Frankenstein you
have created a monster and it will
destroy you
and you're alluding
I have seen the movie though it is a
good movie you know what I'm talking
about Governor it's like when Dr
Frankenstein creates a monster then
loses control of the monster and in the
book obviously the monster ends up
killing him well look at the end you
know the parallel I'm making at the end
of the day
um you know what's best for the country
and let's put the country first rather
than worry about any personalities or
any type of individual um as you know at
the end of the day I'm a vessel for the
aspirations of the people I represent
it's really not about me that's true but
you're up against somebody who
definitely cares who gets the credit
who's desperate to want to win back the
White House and prove that his theory
that he had it wrong well I'm not up
against anybody you know quite yet we're
up against the polls please have you two
yeah up here and everybody else down
here so if you do the way the way I view
it though but the way I view it though
if I were to to run I'm running against
Biden like we're competing for the
Republican potentially I get that but
ultimately you know the guy I'm going to
focus on is buying because I think he's
I think he's failed the country I think
the country wants a change I think they
want a fresh start in a New Direction
and so we'll be very vocal about that
you can beat bud I think so
so you're running them no I didn't say
that I just said I think I could I mean
I think that that's I mean if you look
at Florida it would be harder to be
Biden or Donald Trump workout I don't
know those are two different the
difference I mean if you do decide to
run I mean let's you know we can pretend
around the horses here but if you do
decide to run in the next few months
obviously it will then be UV Donald
Trump for the Republican nomination
people have been quite kind of scathing
they've said you're house trained Donald
your diet coke to his full Coke right
you've heard all this stuff
what are the differences between you
well I mean I think there's a few things
I mean obviously you know the the
approach to covid was different I mean
you know I would have fired somebody
like fauci uh I think that he got way
too big for his britches and I think he
did a lot of damage I also think just in
terms of my approach to leadership you
know I get Personnel in the government
who have the agenda of the people and
share our agenda if you bring your own
agenda in you're gone we're just not
going to have that so the way we run the
government I think is no daily drama
focus on the big picture and put points
on the board and I think that that's
something that's very important you've
not been sucked into responding to any
of the taunts is a deliberate strategy
I'm just not following it I mean I get
taunted and I get attacked every day I
mean you see some of that I it to me
it's just kind of background noise it's
not important for me to be fighting with
people on social media it's not
accomplishing anything for the people I
represent I just wanted to shut your
fingers for a moment
because I've noticed they're very
slimmed down Ron DeSantis you've lost a
lot of weight recently
well we're you know at the end of the
day it's like New Year's resolution just
get back in the swing of things the same
thing I'm a vet I'm a athlete and a
military veteran and so as Governor you
can get caught up in a lot of other
stuff apparently no carbs and no dessert
so I think the sugar is the biggest
issue because like basically if you do
sugar your body Burns sugar if you don't
it burns fat and so if you're working
out and just eating halfway decent I'm
doing exactly the same thing by the way
since Christmas that's what we're almost
together there you go you're probably
doing a bit better than me but I was
asking about your fingers because of
this I mean Scandal which broke last
week that you apparently were eating
chocolate pudding with three fingers now
where did was that Anonymous sources or
something very serious allegation in
fact I congratulated the journalist who
broke it on the new Watergate but I have
to put it to you Governor have you ever
eaten a chocolate pudding with three
fingers I don't remember ever doing that
I'm telling you maybe when I was a kid
but it's interesting you know there's a
lot of people when you're when they go
at you sometimes they have like really
good ammunition like you're a crook you
stood this you did that for me they're
talking about pudding like is that
really the best you got okay bring it on
Governor it's been great to meet you
yeah and to get Under the Skin a bit of
Governor Ron DeSantis
who knows next few months maybe we'll
come and interview again when you're
running for president I'm glad you came
to Tallahassee I know it's your first
time and we welcome you to Florida's
historic Capital next time you're in St
Andrews in Scotland we got to do that
let's have a little I can get out there
we got to do that little battle on the
old course yeah that'd be like that'd be
England v America by the best man we've
got local knowledge we've only played it
once paid back for George III there you
go good to meet you hey thank you
appreciate you appreciate your time
well that's it from
it for a malatician but those two big
questions remain are Ron DeSantis will
he run for president and if he if he
does
can he win
that's all so good night and remember
Keep It Uncensored
[Music]
thank you
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
I'm Sarah Houston his decision that's
questionable not the book frankly it
doesn't do Andrew any favors having this
dripped back into the media I think they
really only care if they come again
Americans love that Royal fairy tale
common ground which is desperately by
the way what the two houses of Windsor
and Montecito need to find is that what
this is about here inviting all his
mates
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it